字幕志愿者 杨茜茜
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
字幕志愿者 李宗盛
有聽到聲音幫我加個1啊
有聽到聲音加個1
剛從金山
回來啊
剛從金山回來又去基隆
去基隆廟口
基隆廟口
然後回來呢
這個又去火鍋店
因為有學員來火鍋店
這個
去那邊跟他們拍個照
聊個天
趕回來 趕快直播
好啦
那...欸...這個大盤呢
已經開啟人道走廊了啦
然後呢有些股票齁
這個長線呢來看已經跌很多
講到什麼
今天我講到皮克明了
這個在...
在那個什麼
在...
在基隆廟口我問一下基隆廟口有夾到皮克棉我把位置調整一下哦基隆廟口有等一下等一下弄一下基隆廟口夾到皮克棉位置調整一下基隆廟口夾到皮克棉
基隆廟口的娃娃我覺得還蠻多樣的
好啦
我聽到聲音喔
那我們來看這個
很忙,很忙,今天非常忙
大家請幫我按個讚啊
幫我按個讚
我的訂閱呢 給各位看一下
我的訂閱已經快到10萬了
目標就是10萬
我來看一下
現在看一下 哇現在9.7萬人了
9.7萬人了 歡迎各位幫我按個訂閱
按個訂閱 啊剛剛這個
這個
好聽的音樂呢 就是這邊
秋天的鋼琴音樂
武版權音樂 我們都要放武版權的
因為你放油版權
放油版權會有一些問題
反正只能放五版權的
然後
我現在有9.7萬個訂閱者
重新整理一下 看會變多
沒有 幫我按個訂閱好嗎
按一下訂閱啦
按一下動個小指頭 按按訂閱
10萬會抽娃娃
10萬抽娃娃
皮克明喔
皮克明
皮克明在樓下
應該在樓下
一個皮克明的帽子
還有小隻的皮克明
發現基隆沒有火夜市還蠻多的
那股市秋天了嗎
股市當然是秋天啦
股市秋天啊
我覺得現在的股市真的要小心一點
那我們在很久以前呢
就跟各位講了
這個很多股票
很多股票這個都已經怎麼樣
很多高價股都入秋了
所以這個位置本來就是要很小心的地方
那你假如開很高槓桿了
其實最近呢 會玩得很心驚膽跳
假設你沒有一些空單
那我們習慣性開槓桿
所以呢 我們一定會有空單保護
而且呢 我們每天早上呢
每天早上都會做一件事情
等等 等我一下 忘了打燈啊
打燈一下
我先打個燈打個燈燈不夠亮
好啦 站我比較亮
好 這個
我的燈不是原燈啦 它是台燈而已
因為原燈都很暗
所以 欸 聊到哪邊
這個
很多股票他都已經進入了
進入了這個秋天期
每天早上我們都會做短空
例如說我今天做了3532
3532台勝科
那各位看一下
他的基期太高了
第一個台勝科的基期太高了
他現在
現在
各位看一下
他的
他的年限
來來來
我把他年限弄出來給各位看
年限在這裡
年限在這邊喔 年限163
然後股價今天早上有到466
所以它這乖離年限
這不知道幾%
那乖離年限很多的喔
後面很多都沒有好下場
再跟各位講一次
乖離年限大概到兩三百%以上喔
它的壓力都很大
乖離年限兩三百%以上
什麼概念呢
來 給各位看喔
這裡喔
之前
被動元件
各個都是乖離年限兩三百%以上
結果呢
後面疊最深的就是被動元件
被動元件一堆在兩三百%以上的
乖離年限
乖離年限就說跟年限比起來
今年平均每個人
每個人都賺到兩百%以上
平均賺到兩百%以上
那時候是一堆被動元件
現在全部沒了
有沒有
現在全部不見了
全部沒有了
現在歸離年限第一名叫旭蘭
這什麼股票啊 不知道
不知道這什麼股票 這很小心啊
那第二名叫台勝科啊 有沒有
所以台勝科呢 他已經跑到第二名去了
所以呢 今天當然是空他啊
反正歸離年限只要是200%以上
200%以上 他的壓力呢 都會很大
都很大 所以歸離年限200%以上
你就不要說什麼
啊 看給我的大國劇
沒有什麼大國劇了 好不好
歸年線200%以上 那個
光均線乖離的賣壓齁
就很嚴重
就很嚴重 所以各位呢 你一定要知道這個歸年線 歸年線是我長期在看的歸年年限只要200%以上那壓力都很大我很少看到乖離年限200%以上可以撐很久
再講一次喔
很少看到
乖離年限200%以上可以撐很久
喔 那負乖離不可能200%啦
負乖離不可能
現在負乖離最大的76%
喔 76% 這裡就很大了
那正乖離最大的233%
那現在剩下一堆100多趴
所以一堆股票都已經怎麼樣
都已經大幅回到
以前我們看到兩三百趴以上的一堆
現在呢一堆以上呢
都已經剩下不到100趴了
被動元件一堆剩不到100趴
被動元件現在比較撐的有
我們來看
我把這個找被動出來
被套元件
以前是叫
暴動元件
現在叫被套元件
那現在被掏眼線最強的是和聲堂
和聲堂 和聲堂還有165%
添了121% 西瓦117%
沒有啊 沒有了
沒有了 全部都疊下來
華興哥已經準備要連線
連線那個保衛戰了
華興哥這次疊你看疊到多少
來 我們把他的這幾條線都畫出來
我們把這個均線畫出來
60 240 然後我再畫個120
我畫個120的線
給各位看一下
華新科2492
來這邊
這邊呢是季線 季線破了
然後呢 一下子來到半年線
現在120是半年線喔
接下來是他的年線 年線240
年線目前位置在176塊
我覺得一下跌到年線應該是不至於
我強烈覺得他從這裡開始
他的慣性會改變
今天有點像離開這個下軌的紅K
因為他現在是沿著下軌
所以今天有點像離開下軌的紅K
只差他沒離開而已
不然有點像離開下軌的紅K
對不對 很像喔
然後今天是大摩進來買
大摩 欸各位 這大摩是厲害的喔
大摩賣掉嘛
你看 各位看 645塊他賣的
然後最近呢 他開始大幅的接回來
大魔
大魔是厲害的
土城永寧我就不用講了嘛 對不對
吼 土城永林 好不好 土城永林也很厲害喔 各位
喔 你 你在做的事情叫貪評
土城永林做的叫布局啦 好不好
他390買華新科
喔 390買華新科
然後一直疊一直疊 人家在布局 好不好
不是貪評 好不好 各位
大戶叫做布局 好不好
他只是在埋伏 在布局
你在這裡買往下接你才叫攤平
好不好 人家大戶是布局
好不好 布局
布局齁
那布局呢 他今天又大買
今天又大買
那其實被動元件在這邊齁
我曾經試過單
試過單就是 我就丟一點點
丟個幾張 欸
立馬賠錢 賠錢沒關係
賠錢呢 我就
就在撐一下
賠錢就在撐一下
反正只有一點點幾張而已
幾張而已賠錢沒關係 無所謂
我就等他有一天
我一定要喝你的把他大買
那就是今天了
我今天分成幾個戶頭去買
我今天有分幾個戶頭去買華其英科
那我有PO我的其中一個戶頭
這是其中一個戶頭而已
事實上我是分幾個戶頭
我有給各位看一下
我分幾個戶頭
這是其中一個戶頭
給各位看 這裡
華新科
那華新科這個
我買260
251的是我特別講
特別講
那時候我在discord講
那個說
251塊怎麼樣
我們叫做
Final Call
飛機要起飛了
各位
這個飛機要起飛了
現在是Final Call
要登機的
不是空軍喔
要登機的就是往上飛
251塊是往上飛的最後一刻了
那為什麼251是往上飛的最後一刻呢
為什麼是最後一刻呢
為什麼251是最後一刻
各位看一下251開始起飛
那時候我就講說251是最後一刻了
在這個位置
那這個位置為什麼是最後一刻呢
為什麼
這個我們最近極度會抓轉折
我不止251最後一刻呢
我還買到一個也是最後一刻要登機的最後一刻我都非常喜歡我不是我非常喜歡買在不是最低點是最低點的下一點
我超喜歡買在最低點的下一點
因為最低點下面可能還有更低點
但我買在最低點的下一點
就是最低點的下一刻
就是我買在
比最低點再高一個位置
不一定是一個Ticker
但是就是
最低價在網上
然後之後呢就沒有更低價了
我最喜歡買在這地方
那我就買一個位置
來來
今天呢我也買了一個叫做日電帽
那3090日電帽呢
我在這個位置呢
我在這個點
我在這個價格
這價格我買了
我買了172張
我張宗舟給你看啦
172 有沒有 172
日天貓我買了172喔
172 我是買在這一盤
這個這一盤呢
他這邊啊 163
這一盤 我買了172
那買完之後呢
下一盤168
再下一盤168 168 175.5
這
681張我佔了172
可能我買多 太多了點
讓他直接連跳了3塊
我講買少一點齁
他可能就不會跳3塊 可能跳2塊
但是買少一點 我的張數又不夠多
所以我就 這個是兩欄啦
我買的越多 他跳的越高
所以我又不希望他滑價滑得很厲害
所以我的單子是分批 分批掛
我是分批往下掛
可是有些價格一定重
例如說在160的時候我就掛170
170一定重啦
我掛170啊 165啊
160.5啊 161啊 我掛一堆
160.5跟161就沒有中 我就中163
齁 就是
這163以上我都中 齁 各位你要記得
綽額的邏輯喔
163代表什麼意思 代表你掛163以上你都會中
齁 啊這個 綽額的價格到底怎麼來 綽額的價格呢
他是 這個 綽額的時候 他去找一個
成交量最大量的位置
163是成交量最大量的位置
所以我的單子 我假如掛沒有很多的話
那可能成交最大量是162.5或162
所以這163呢
我是影響到他的價格但我覺得沒差因為我覺得我覺得日電貿大概這個位置呢是短線的低點我覺得是短線低點啦
短線低點
那我覺得短線就是可能
這一兩天
這一兩個
這個
那個
欸
這兩天
或
大概是
欸這幾盤啊
這幾盤啊
因為它現在是20分鐘一盤嘛
那我163到175.5
各位看我的那個
我的未實現存因就有
12.5元
乘上
12.5元乘上多少
乘上172張嗎
12.5乘上172張
200萬
光這一筆的未實現是200萬
然後這邊呢
2492今天說多少
2492273
你看我這251買的多漂亮
對不對
所以我們就說
我們會在關鍵時刻
其實我們不怕賠錢啦
我不怕賠錢
就是我買了賠錢
這個我早一天我一定會報仇的啦
跟各位講
我早一天一定會報仇的
很狠的報仇
報完仇之後呢
就是在後面我就很好賣了
我第一筆的單子成交多少
成交300多都無所謂
但是呢我會在關鍵時刻買一個大量
那為什麼關鍵時刻買一個大量
為什麼有能力這樣子
因為資金控管好嗎
你前面ALL IN了
你後面都不用玩的
再跟各位講
你前面ALL IN後面不用玩
那什麼狀況下你前面會ALL IN呢
什麼狀況下你前面會ALL IN
就是
你太
你太偏多了嘛
但我們早就跟你講這盤有問題
這個
千元股票一堆是秋天股
這盤一定有問題
一定会出事情 早就跟你讲了
我们老早就跟你讲 它一定会有问题
一定会有个修正 一定会有个去杠杆
我们说它一定会有个去杠杆在
也真的 它真的在去杠杆
它真的 最近一直在去杠杆
最近很多融资被断了 所以它在去杠杆中
所以呢
你說錢太少
錢太少可以買零股啊
各位 你又不一定要買整股不一定要買整股 你可以買零股啊那大概兩天前兩天前 那個一般的券商公司
一般的期貨公司 他們已經發了一堆期貨追剿
所以最近我們都看到盤中有些期貨的停損單
都看得出來
有期貨的停損單出來
欸 等一下 等一下
我們會看到一些期貨停損單
那未來呢 會有些貨追剿零
你看一下華興科的維持率你就知道了
那現在的維持率都比低的啊
有沒有來來來來給我看
現在的維持率
我找一下
我的維持率有這裡
融資維持率有沒有
哇華興科維持率109
有沒有109
怎麼看盤中提損單很簡單嘛
這個內外盤差很多 他一直砍內盤就是停損單啊
一般人他不會一直砍內盤啊
莫名其妙砍內盤這個停損單
然後處置轉折怎麼抓的可以抓到最低眼下盤
來來來
來這裡喔
處置轉折怎麼抓的可以抓到最低眼下盤
問得很好
請你去PB問
我們再PB回答
我最近PV的問題喔
我真的是很沒力
給我看我們那個前兩天
哇9999
喔這邊999
為什麼為什麼這999
有沒有看到
你看一下我這篇文章
我這篇文章
我的回的留言
這邊
我11000看過這篇文章
我光QA啊
這個QA喔
30分鐘
然後這個QA呢
因為我要分三段啦 因為不分三段喔
他的那個影片太長有時候
系統會讓這個影片會出問題
這邊呢 9分鐘
所以我花了整整70分鐘在解答QA
喔
花了70分鐘解答QA
為什麼 因為前一天的QA呢
前一天QA有100多題
然後我就跟學員講
你不要在這裡問說
要不要買 要不要賣
我不回答這個問題啊
不回答說
欸 多少錢要買 多少錢要賣
你問這個問題太low了 好不好
我們不回答這個問題
多少錢要買 多少錢要賣 你可以去找投顧老師
問他說 請問多少錢要買 多少錢要賣
他就會先問你一個問題
請問你有多少錢
他講跟他說 我有那個3萬塊
他會跟你說
那你還是去
去旁邊玩殺好了
你去看訂閱好了
看訂閱好了 你看訂閱
看什麼 有什麼訂閱區 完訂閱
去看訂閱
因為資金不夠多 人家不想收
你講資金有
老子 我有一千萬
你有一千萬
歡迎加入我們的清代會員
清代會員
一季的那個 會費呢
250萬
四季收乾
四季收乾是他們的政策
就是四季
四季看能不能把你的錢收光
我們也是看到這四季收乾
我講 四季收乾 剩下
你花250萬剩下750萬
你要先賺250萬
那你一季要賺250萬
你的報酬率要多少啊
各位有沒有想過這個問題啊
你750萬一季要賺250萬
你的年化報酬要多少
你的那個不算年化報酬
你的實際報酬大概要30幾%
然後一季的話
那代表說你年化報酬100多%
100多% 你以為那麼容易啊
非常不容易 好不好 非常不容易
但是所以呢 你要問該不該買 該不該賣
你就不要來問我了
我不是來解決你該不該買 該不該賣的人
好不好
這個要解決這個問題的人呢
請去找投顧老師
我是來看一下這個籌碼到底好不好
籌碼到底好不好
那我們
我們長期是做短線的
所以呢
因為我們長期做短線
所以呢 我們對那個轉折呢
很敏銳
那我也呢
我也不會跟你講幹話
那什麼叫講幹話呢
欸老師老師 請問華新科有沒有救啊
問華新科有沒有救
華新科有救啦
各位 你只要等到他反彈
月線重新翻揚往上
他就有救了
呵呵呵呵對 他只要跟你講這句話你等到他月線翻揚往上 他就有救了我等到月線翻揚往上不知道 起幾百塊而已啊 對不對
不知道漲幾百塊了
好不好
不知道漲幾百塊了 你再等他死之後 悶死了
華星客月線翻揚往上 我一定把我的庫存全部賣掉
為什麼
因為等到月線翻揚往上 我不知道賺多少
對不對 你看我今天買250、260
越界翻延往上大概可能400多塊
那我賺多少了對不對
其實重點是
哪個點位是最漂亮的
你知道嗎 哪個點位最漂亮
這是重點
哪個點位最漂亮呢
我有跟你講 好不好
我有跟你講
這個
你講我不知道的
歡迎訂閱
我今天再跟你講一次
我今天呢 我再跟你講一次
我為什麼要在251、26
163塊
買華信跟日電帽
齁
那同帽
同帽我是空單回補啊
各位
同帽我是空的很漂亮
同帽空的很漂亮
因為你去看一下同帽
同帽
同帽幾號我都忘記了
同帽我的點位非常漂亮
來 儲置股的
欸 頭帽欸
頭帽跑去哪
這邊 2 4 3 4
我空在這一天
我空在這一天 2 4 3 4
今天是我的回補日
我空完了
账面還賠錢
剛空完账面還賠錢
為什麼一當天拉漲停嘛
所以我空完账面還賠錢
沒差啦 對不對 沒差 為什麼
因為後面 隔點點點
再隔點點點 再隔點點
那為什麼要這樣空呢
其實你看主力馬來超你就知道
但其實他沒有多強
他主力馬來超沒有多強
沒有多強
啊但是呢 李小在這裡問老師
欸 老師老師 統帽你怎麼看
哇塞 統帽這個點位
這點位非常的
這股票非常的強勢
各位 你看他軍線全部都翻揚往上
他是強強的大多頭啊同樣老師 老師同帽今天怎麼辦這根長紅K各位
守住長紅K的上緣
同帽就會往上
只要跌破長紅K
同帽就會往下
所以呢
未來很重要
你一定要看同帽有沒有守住90.8塊
有守住90.8塊的話
10.8塊的話
那麼
頭帽就有機會往上
廢話
我說90塊的話再往上啊
對不對
那假如跌破90.8
假如跌破這根紅K的下人
跌破這根紅K的下人
那麼
頭帽就會往下走
廢話
你會講點震驚的
震驚的什麼
頭冒這根或者空下去而已
管他9000
管
管他打王可以管他漲停
我再來扛下去
把他空下去
為什麼空下去
因為各位看一下
他的籌碼是架籌備
我們早就要修理他了
我們只是等時間而已
等時間而已
你說我空在漲停
我不是空在漲停
我是空完他漲停啦
各位
他漲停我也不想空啊
我也不想空
我是空完他漲停 各位
欸你誤會我了 我不是叫你空漲停
我是空完他漲停啊
他漲了之後跌下來 跌下來嘛
我在這裡開始空 空空空
咳 給我拉漲停
有沒有 給我拉漲停
太可惡了
居然敢給我拉漲停
可惡
那要停損嗎 不用停損 為什麼
為什麼不用停損
因為
因為他被關20分鐘
我就不相信 你是
你是多厲害
對不對 後面被關了
後面被關沒了
重點是他架籌背離
你知道嗎
重點是架籌背離
OK
你不能價格往上
你的籌碼往下
那這架籌背離
早就知道他架籌背離
我在這裡我就知道他架籌背離了
我怎麼找時間修理他
你懂我的意思嗎
我找時間修理他 找時間我就看日子嘛
我看好日子 哇塞你頭冒 你再長上去
你要面臨20分鐘你最好20分鐘再這麼暢秋啦再這麼暢秋 你懂嗎你有總20分鐘再給我暢秋那我認了我認了 我就停損嘛 對不對
我就
我就10%賭你個未來
對不對 我空下去
大不了我停損10%
大不了我停損10%嘛
對不對
10%我大不了都想停損啦
啊不然你的債視對不對
你怪離月線這麼多
你都不用回來
對不對
都不用回來
跟各位講 最近的盤
是空單只要乖離很大的
最終都回來
最終都回來喔
空單只要乖離很大
最終都回來
所以你不要說
啊 各位
你一定呢
這個股票呢
有軍縣派跟你講
啊這股票你不用怕啦
只要怎麼樣
只要手穩月線
他就會往上攻
手穩月線
欸 老師
這裡手穩了嗎
這裡帶月線以上當然不要賣啊
這裡要賣嗎
月線以上賣什麼股票
你要看他有沒有手穩月線
跌跌跌跌跌
我跌到今天了
老師要賣嗎
不要賣啦
月線又沒跌破幹嘛賣
真正跌破的時候
怎麼樣
要停損好不好
跌破月線要停損
每個獎月均線派都跟你講
來 各位 你要遵守機率
跌破月線要停損
卡好了 我90點巴不賣
你現在跌破月線剩50塊
你叫我停損
你的停損點就是我的買點
你停損了 我要進去買
哇塞 這個有人停損
這個點好漂亮 你知道嗎
這點好漂亮 我耗我的怎麼樣
我的買進做多了
所以你的停損點就是我的買點
你不想賣的點是我的空點
你懂嗎
因為我們對那個節奏掌握得很好
所以你可以看到我們掌握到連
那個盤中的每一個Ticket
都掌握得很精確
掌握很精確
因為我們對股票的價量
我們是很有FU的
長期看盤了
長期開門就跟你講說
這個卡丁妹
這個位置卡丁妹
第一個趕快買嘛
第二個跟你講說
這裡
這裡是Final Call
Final Call OK?
Final Call
最後上車點了 你再不上車
車子要發動了
各位你等著看吧
看明天
只要大盤不要太爛
我們現在只希望大盤不要太爛
大盤不要太爛
我覺得被動是有機會
我覺得 我個人覺得被動有機會
因為呢 被動是
所有個股裡面
漲最多也跌最深
喔
長最多疊對勝
欸
欸 華新科是打四折欸
這比打六折欸
欸 這比打六折
你知道打四折什麼概念嗎
欸 打七折 週年慶
打四折已經淪落花車了
你知道嗎 花車你知道嗎
你去買衣服 我要跟你講說去花車撿
旁邊花車撿
那他的籌碼有多爛嗎
主力沒跑喔
有沒有 主力沒有跑啊
有沒有 這也是主力沒有跑
喔 所以我覺得華新科沒有這麼爛啊
從籌碼來看他沒有這麼爛
但是呢 他就一直被關嘛
那一直被關一直被關
被關被關被關
那華新科我們到底要看什麼東西呢
到底要看什麼東西
我又跟你講 好不好
老師有講你到底有沒有在聽啊 有沒有
老師有講老師有發文跟你講
有沒有 老師有發文跟你講這邊這邊這邊
我來發文跟你講這裡
華新科在處置期間只要可以超過5000張的量
就有機會反攻
被動那時候才比較會有春天
我是不是有發文跟你講
5000張有沒有
你看這幾張
哎呦這4800這麼大
有沒有看到
這個量是不是我們跟你講
這個量是
第一次
他一直跌下來
第一次超過5000張而且是超過很多
我說5000張
非常的關鍵
簡單很關鍵簡單嘛這是一個加量關係嘛你至少要讓這5000張想賣的人把它賣掉嘛有沒有
很簡單的邏輯嘛
5000張想賣要賣掉啊
那5000張他斷頭斷不掉啊
你要讓他斷掉嘛
你要那5000張想賣的賣掉
對不對
那5000張的賣壓
我今天幫忙化解了嘛
我幫忙化解了
我這個戶頭就化解了100張
100多啦
我這戶頭化解了100多張
我還有其他戶頭 我今天大概化解了200張
我化解了200張 5000張我救了200個人出來
所以我今天負責幫一堆人解套了
希望接下來套的不是我
這次短線搶版單 有沒有
我給你講了嘛 我給你講 我給你PO了
PO了講了 對不對
Poller講的做了
有什麼可以這麼精確事前跟你講
隔天做給你看
後面我不知道
後面搞不好我要停損欸 對不對
後面搞不好我要停損
搞不好我挺利欸
其實我明天開盤平盤賣掉
我也爽爽賺
好不好
明天開盤賣掉我是爽爽賺
我也賺這個一兩百萬
對不對
那日電冒明天開盤
平盤叫我賣掉我也賺一兩百萬
我全部在哪邊幹的呢
我全部在這個金山週季酒店幹的
金山週季酒店操板室
我今天在這裡面幹的這些事情
全部都在這裡面做
你們坐在這邊
各位看這是我的螢幕
一個螢幕 兩個 三個螢幕
我有三個螢幕
我是覺得金山週季酒店真的是
我覺得莊王很讚
很讚 真的
真的很讚
但是呢
真的很貴
超貴啊
各位啊
給你看一下
唉唷 怕死人
超貴
隨便選個時間
隨便選那麼貴
我建議各位喔 禮拜一去
禮拜一去比較便宜
我就禮拜一去啊
我問他還是蠻貴的
齁
那你千萬不要去什麼Hotel Agoda Booking都不要好不好 都不要喔你要去那個
叫做什麼
優越會啦 優越會
趕快去加入那個洲際大使
洲際大使呢只要花你大概
7000多塊的
200多塊的美金嘛
7000多塊的台幣
想有什麼東西喔
再跟各位講 你可以想有什麼東西
想有4點Check out
4點欸
你平常11點Check out
你現在可以玩到4點欸
玩到4點差多少
差5點錢欸
然後又送你一堆券
算一算很划算
真的很划算啊
後面還會送你那個
那個週季的週末酒店券
光那個就超過會費了啦
你懂嗎
重點是他多5個鐘頭
本來11點退房變成
變成那個4點退房
我們這種
而且跟各位講我覺得他最神奇的是
他早餐怎麼樣
他早餐是
到下午2點
早餐到下午2點
我記得我每次住飯店
早餐早上10點結束
拜託交易做到9點50分
正刺激
就9點50分下去
然後菜夾一夾
對不對
然後開始吃
吃一吃
吃到10點半
人家開始趕你了
因為中午要開始了
對不對 吃得很狼狽
結果這邊呢
2點
2點退
可以吃到2點
所以早上呢
下下單
這個
浩枕
浩枕以霞
浩枕以霞去吃個飯
吃到2點
回去還可以睡個午覺
睡個午覺呢 再去遊個湯
再回來退個房
退完房還可以再去泡個湯
然後
5點多才離開
整個用好用滿
超讚的 我是覺得很讚的
你早點訂你用那個
金山優越會其實大概
1萬
1萬1 1萬2
要挑日子 要挑平日
平日的平日
晚上還很貴
禮拜天晚上比較貴
那禮拜...欸唷他沒有欸這個禮拜天沒有,這禮拜天還不錯反正早點訂啦這很好用松山哥匯播到哪裡出貨
松山哥匯播到哪裡出貨
你回去看昨天的PP
有跟你講
我們有抓到兩檔他匯播的證據
兩檔在昨天跟前一天都有講
各位 有看到的加個1啊
這個你知道
松山哥會在哪邊出貨的幫我打個加1
好不好
幫我打個加1
你知道松山哥在哪邊出貨的幫我打個加1
你知道的加1
你看 喔 你看 全部都知道
大家都知道 好不好
就你不知道
為什麼你不知道
因為你沒有加入我們的PPE
所以你不知道
因為這個是有人問啦
其實我也沒有去研究
這是我沒有去研究
只是有人問嘛
那我們就幫他看一下
唉唷 找到了
找到了他的老巢
那我們就發現兩檔
發現兩檔
他那個出貨的痕跡
出貨的痕跡很明顯啦
想知道松山哥的秘密
請用九折優惠券
好不好 九折優惠券
好啦
那這幾個QR Code 各位可以加一下
然後我們這個
全小哥討論群
這個Light
4個8
好不好 4個8
嗯
對啊
這個本來還以為松山哥多純情
多純情 多浪漫
多麼深情款款
多麼山盟海事
結果並沒有
並沒有 好不好
一樣 跟以前一樣
有比較好啦
以前常常一夜勤
以前就是今天買明天賣
有好一點 好不好
這個從一個一頁變兩頁變三頁變四頁
太多料了
PP加入單月的全部都看得到
全部都看得到
偷偷換房間
對偷偷換房間
沒錯
松山哥偷偷換房間
的確是這樣
我把那個留言拉上來一下
留言我要從這邊看
喔 鼻子很超直啊
超直啊
我跟你講
再跟各位講一次
很多
很多訊號它都是落後訊號
再跟各位講一次
他都是落後訊號
落後訊號什麼意思 就是
你等到
等到真的那訊號出現了
你也不用做了 不用做了
什麼事都不用做了
不然你去問
你問軍縣派老師 華新科到底要怎麼辦
但跟你講 你就要等到
所有軍縣翻養才能再進場啊
所有軍縣翻養才能再進場
這到底是多少肉啊
肉有多大不肥嗎
對不對 華新科假如現在所有均線都翻養
那肉 你看肉肥不肥 肉超肥好不好
華新科現在有一堆均線都往下
來 我們把那個比較
比較那個520
那個這邊啊 這邊有一堆均線都往下
唉唷 那我均線跑去哪
布林通話 均線在
均線沒
這
這裡
你自己看
黃線太黃了
你看
你要買一定要等到這均印線全部翻養
等到翻養
那彈上來
彈上來讓它真的翻養我都想賣
對不對我都想賣了好不好
其實這個點怎麼樣
這點肥啊
肥啊 各位
我們從地板股也看得出來
今天地板股有他 我還沒看地板股啦
但是我猜有他
因為我有去算量
我們盤中就在算量了
欸 華晶哥
沒有
怎麼會沒有
看一下
喔 沒有超過兩倍
算錯
我還以為有勒
錯估錯估 差一點 那可能就明天了
喔
啊我...這個沒辦法,因為他處置啦
這就想到
他處置真的很困難啦
對啦,你不能怪他
不過他已經比昨天已經多十倍了
好不好
昨天都十倍了
比昨天多十倍,這很強了好不好
很強了,因為他
因為他處置啦好不好
因為他處置
要趕進度喔,去醫藥路
喔對喔 天啊 我們前面講一下就講到這邊好啦 趕快看一下這邊4個8 各位加一下加一下我們的這個社群
4個8
單月訂閱跟年訂閱更新頻率都一樣
都一樣 只是你付的錢不一樣
都一樣
只是你付的錢不一樣
好
那直播注意事項 各位自己看一下
現在看這個上週中獎名單
市長從不確定分析的人
確實把因為把複雜變成
把經驗變成方法的人
組織成績讓我佩服的是
不只是他的功能
還是承載小哥多年實戰累積的機會
每次打開成績都提醒我
實在價值不是招到一張股票
而是有人願意把自己獨搶的經驗
毫無保留的分享給大家
真的是粗心比任何獲利還敬佩
恭喜恭喜
好
我現在只是講均線啦
我沒有再提任何老師啦
好不好 就講均線
只是跟各位講均線呢 它有時候比較慢
那有時候均線也好用啦
也不是說均線很難用 只是有時候很慢
就太慢了
所以呢
這個 我們的方法
從籌碼 從量價來看
那個是最快的
好不好
從籌碼量價來看是最快的
再講一次喔
籌碼 量價
齁 那籌碼量價呢 就是我們會去分辨嘛
就像我跟妳講 華新科今天已經怎麼樣
華新科今天 欸
來來來 華新科我們再講一下
華新科今天誰賣的
肉腳賣隔離嘛
就是1R 肉咖 對不對
肉腳賣隔離 上面不停立 底下拼命賣
唉唷唉唷 你不能講他肉腳 人家在這裡買
呵呵呵 這是真的
不愛賣 這邊有肉腳啦
那我能賣在這裡的啦
有沒有 賣在這裡幹嘛
肉腳賣隔離嗎
我已經把賣隔離的賣壓給化解了啦
啊賣隔離每天都掛單嘛 對不對
那我就把他的賣壓給化解了
明天沒有賣隔離了啦
有沒有
明天沒有賣隔離了 對不對
欸對不對 欸是不是是不是
喔 我把賣隔離
喔呦呦
我把這麼多年的賣格里的賣壓都化解掉了啦
喔 可以了吧
我把這麼多年的賣格里的賣壓都化解掉了今天把它都化解掉了OK所以呢明天至少賣隔離
想賣的
已經不會賣了
今天賣隔離全部都可以賣啦
他今天是不是全部都可以賣
他想賣都可以賣啊
他今天賣得很爽啊
有沒有
今天賣隔離賣得很爽啊
他想賣多少都賣得掉啊
他都賣得掉啊
今天賣隔離都賣得掉
明天沒有賣隔離了好不好
應該沒有啦 應該沒有賣隔離了
明天少了賣隔離
明天還有誰會賣 我不知道
喔 啊富邦我也化解掉一些了嘛
永豐金
喔 可憐啦
我也化解掉了嘛 對不對
對不對 啊這邊都有化解掉一些東西啊
欸 今天還有誰賣啊
投信嘛 唉呦 唉
唉 是哪個漏腳投信
呵呵
是哪個肉腳頭信啊
來來來來
我們來看一下是哪個肉腳頭信
我我查一下查一下
這幾個肉咖啦
那我來買這個地方對不對
我們每次都在幫頭信那個
頭信撿屍啊
齁
每次都幫頭信撿屍來來來
來吧
我們再來推置小雨的投資日記
登登
籌碼小雨對不對
來來來
欸 29在那邊
股票反查ETF啦
好不好 各位加一下啦
籌碼小雨 嘎嘎啦
好不好 欸免費
免費的做的這麼高級的對不對
免費做這麼高級的
這上面講00991A
喔
喔 主動復華
哇這什麼貨啦
主動復華
啊拜託欸
你是
喔這什麼主動復華
哪有人這樣啦
哪有人在買這個地方啦
主動復華
這是怎麼做啊
發生什麼事啦
欸那我可以查
991什麼時候買的嗎
欸可以嗎
欸小雨
991什麼時候買
查得出來嗎
小雨小雨
我們讓九九 我們讓那個小雨回答一下九九也怎麼說 九主動復華原來來主動這麼主動喔那就是1喔
主動復華
喔唷
這個頭好大
頭很大捏
這頭那麼大顆不
來來來來
來看他的戶數喔
戶數應該是蠻多的啦
有沒有
噢
噢這個
這個好多人套在山頂啊
好多人套在山頂啊
就只有一個
欸有啦
那個網址有連結啦
啊
6月18號買的
有沒有搞錯啊
蛤?
救救一啊
那怎麼有人在讀這個時候的啦
對不對
你不要拜託欸
早不賣
晚不賣一定要賣在這時候
頭主動
反正不是投信自己的錢啊
你買的你就要買啊
好啦
喔搞不好
搞不好明天華信哥跌停
好不好
主動就來笑小哥了
欸什麼小哥
還好我昨天倒給他
小哥對不對
小哥算什麼
我昨天倒給小哥
害小哥吞根跌停
搞不好是我賠錢
6月18號買2200張喔
天啊
6月18號
買2200張
各位
鄉親父老姐妹們
6月18號買
然後這裡賣
那真的好主動耶
好啦好啦
這怎麼在謾拉共啊 這不知道怎麼講
呵呵呵
欸各位我們沒有誤會他喔
我們沒有誤會他喔
喔
數十百在眼眼
唉唷啊這天是哪個分點買
欸這天是哪個分點啊看一下
欸
看不出來嗎
6月22
我還看不出來勒
哇塞還分開分點勒
欸 分好幾個分點這什麼東西啊
投資人還分好幾個分點然後
然後還要匯播出去賣
欸 是有匯播嗎
這算有匯播嗎
欸 看一下
我們來看一下
看有沒有匯播
6S8統一嘛
欸
匯播了
欸 匯播了
說欸 會播了
欸
還蠻會會播的
蠻會會播的 有沒有
主動
好啦好啦
這種主動我是不敢買啦
我怕了
這也沒辦法啦
好不好
沒辦法因為
他在講啊
這投信的命就是這樣
也不能怪他啦好不好
也不能怪他
因為投信命就這樣
愛的一個Key啊
他一直長對不對
一直長別人有我沒有
怎麼可以
我一定要買得比別人多
我的績效才會贏別人嘛
你懂嗎
別人有我沒有怎麼可以
對不對他就買了
啊結果我這邊一直疊怎麼樣
啊別人有 我也有
怎麼可以
我一定要績效比他好
我一定要砍在他前面
砍在他前面
真的砍了
好啦我就幫他接了啦
就是我啦
欸其實這邊我在空
我記得我在這邊我在空華信科欸
我在這邊準備空華信科
因為華信科要被關了啊
齁
對
嘿
來上小哥的處置課啦欸那個小雨小雨我們要公布那個處置課的那個嗎我賠53.16%
天啊
華新科賠53.16%欸
怕死人欸
各位你們10%沒停損
那不是你們的問題
不是你的問題
好不好
人家主動試ETF
53%才停損
不是你的問題
所以你看我今天是不是逮到了
我逮到了投信的停損哥了嘛
我逮到投信了
我們說停損哥的賣壓
停損哥的賣壓
就是最肥的紅包嘛
早說了嘛 對不對
就是因為有投信狂砍
華新科這段是多疊的啦
有沒有
體驗科連結
因為這個投信他不懂儲置啊
這邊本來就該賣了啊
這裡啊 各位這裡要賣
這邊那麼明顯 這裡不是被關了
這裡被關 這邊是要出貨的啊
你在被關前買股票 你差個派去
你沒有上小哥的儲置課嗎
你沒有上小哥儲置課
小哥儲置課 被關前找賣點嘛
你沒在聽
老師在講你沒在聽
你買
買幾大堆
買這麼多 然後我就空他
其實那時候我空的蠻開心的
因為這杯關一定會跌的嘛 對不對 很簡單
我在看軍線看的很痛苦 我把軍線關了
我們看布林通道很明顯啦 來來
各位 布林通道這邊有點算平行喔
這邊不大像
不大像發展 像平行
其實平行的通道就有賣啊
然後平行的通道呢 我們解釋一下
平行的通道會有賣壓
所以最好不要在平行的上通道接股票
它不是布林壓縮打開
什麼叫布林壓縮打開
這個才叫布林壓縮打開
這不是壓縮啦 那我們這裡壓縮的
你自己看那麼清楚
這邊寬成這樣 這叫哪 叫壓縮
寬成這樣 哪叫壓縮
所以呢 這不是壓縮
那不是壓縮的上通道不要買
當然不要買
這上通道會有壓力的啊
那上通道壓力什麼時候會很容易顯現就是處置被關它就容易跌下來嗎很清嘛991沒有啦欸欸 你還有991嗎
有沒有 欸
欸991還有沒有
欸 結果我還沒查
欸 小雨 小雨
991還有嗎
給你查一下
你看一下991
我查一下 我查一下
這是哪裡的經理人啊
我跟各位講
華新科齁
我來賺三個
我跟各位講
華新科漲三根
都算小事啊
一個股票
你講看喔
100塊回檔六成
100塊是變成40塊
那40塊
再漲個
三根漲停好了
三成 也才52塊
他還是腰斬啊 他還是腰斬 你知道嗎
他還是腰斬 所以他斬個三成算什麼
一點都不算什麼 好不好
一點都不算什麼
好啦 各位我已經把最大的頭性賣壓給處理掉了
齁 我已經處理掉了
齁 各位不用煩惱 我處理掉了啦
那個今天
今天本人已經處理掉了
本人處理掉了
再給各位看證據
證據在這裡
251我處理掉了
251開始
他就再也沒有他的麥芽了
華新客在251過後
251過後這個大量
我都處理掉了
處理掉了
各位
不用煩惱啊
991的我處理掉了
我處理掉了
從今開始
99...沒有...從今開始 華興科
再也沒有這個拖累的頭銜
有沒有 欸 其實還有咧
還有還有
還有其他家啦 還有其他家
等一下...其他家不曉得什麼時候會砍的
還有還有 還沒賣完
這個...我們看這邊買賣超喔
這裡喔
庫存啦 庫存745
到這邊是9831
哇塞 還有9000張
還有9000張
但是我覺得今天應該是
應該是有人讓開
投信說 終於有人接 我都
我都等這天要接我 我昨天不接他為什麼昨天不接他一千多張幹嘛接這千幾天而已 幹嘛要接他 對不對我隔天再處理他 對不對
我要接得很漂亮
一定要接得很漂亮
喔 再跟各位講 明天有反彈
反正有大漲 我就稍微賣一點
因為我知道大家是想要華星科
我賣一點給你們
賣一點
一張一張賣
我們有那個系統耶 可以跟那個
一張一張幫我賣
一張一張賣
就這樣
來來啦 他們
3090是誰
來來來 3090
我哪有花心科學投信
我真的知道
來
3090今天是幫誰收拾啊
看一下
國泰喔
3090今天誰狂賣啊
今天投資賣一點而已欸
不知道看一下
還是融資
欸
融資也還好啊
喔不過今天3090的量還不算特別大
欸也有四倍大啦
也有四倍大
喔環節我嘛
我把 欸 日電帽 處理掉了啦
日電帽 你看
盤中這麼弱 對不對
買一下1638就去掉了 對不對
買了就上去了
我們的專長就是買了要上去啦 好不好
專長就在這邊 買了要上去
我才不會跟你講說 欸 日電帽
喔 日電帽
要站上均線才能接喔 站上均線
我等站上均線 大隊會等到民國幾年 對不對
站上軍線你要等到民國幾年
你真的整個站上軍線我都想賣了
你懂嗎 都想賣了
喔 直播官人很多
今天多少人看啊
唉呦 4300耶
4300喔 4300
好啦 各位
被動元件齁
最困難的兩顆石頭
我已經處理掉了
所以明天
請對被動元件有信心
好不好
為什麼國聚呢
這個我前兩天我在火鍋店有講
各位前兩天我在火鍋店我有講喔
火鍋店
火鍋店找一找
等一下
我去看
我有講喔
被套元件啦 不是被動元件
我有講喔 給你看
火鍋店喔
火鍋店這部片 各位自己去看一下
前天我有講啦
越套越久你就越被動
被動元件
我講啦
看華新科啦
只要華新科打開
國劇就會彈啦
好不好 我們
我們一切的一切預告在前面有沒有
只要華新科打開一切都會談
國際就會談嘛
跟你講呢
那明天華新科日電貿他們的什麼枷鎖
我們都把它處理掉了好不好
我們都處理掉了
所以呢
在籌碼上基本上那些受不了的人
完全處理掉啊
所以基本上籌碼面我是覺得沒有什麼太大問題
因為我沒有什麼
我沒有什麼停損的賣壓 你懂嗎
我沒有停損的賣壓
我沒有 我這個位置我停什麼損
我買150停什麼損 你懂嗎
買150我不用停損
他現在170我幹嘛停損
你知道嗎
我買151現在
251現在270我停什麼損
我沒有停損的賣壓
我好整以下
你買200倍給你
200倍給你
300倍給你
你買都給你
反正我250倍賣
你要我給你
300億
各位要不要追你家的事
反正有漲我要賣嘛
有漲我要賣OK的啊
那可以的啊
本來股票就低買高賣嘛
那邊低買高賣很正常啊
但是我跟你講
那個最大最大的魔王
出力了啊
最大最大魔王
就是投信
這個投信
這個我們常講
投信就這樣
還主動行
這主動欸
昨天跟他講
套很久會被動
結果他居然
主動了
主動把他處理掉
那個
居然怎麼樣
居然以時間負50幾%
太恐怖了吧
以時間負50幾%
你也要讀 你也在這裡讀讀欸
你怎麼讀
你知道嗎台股算了 我跟你講被動看華新科被動看華新科嘛
那華新科我處理掉了
所以呢
被動就沒什麼大問題了
現在
欸 大摩有停損賣壓嗎
欸 人家賺1700 什麼停損賣壓
他只有獲利了結的賣壓
欸 土城永齡有停損賣壓嗎
人家賺260
只有獲利了結的賣壓
獲利了結的賣壓的慢慢賣就好啦
對不對 我不用隨便砍啊
我沒有人叫我砍啊
沒人叫我去投降
所以這些都是籌碼安定的 有沒有
現在買方是籌碼安定的
賣方最不安定的被我們處理掉了
賣方內歸要求提準 有可能啦
說真的 有可能內歸要求提準
這種最不安定的
我會處理掉啊
所以 我個人是這麼覺得
台股要看被動
就是我們講中小型股
因為台股現在是撐雞盤
把台積電撐住
然後其他股票一直出貨
台股現在是把台積電撐住
所以你會看到怎麼樣
台股還沒有下多少
台股有跌多少
48000到現在4萬4打9折
打9折 那我打多少
打9折大家哀哀叫 為什麼哀叫
因為你說打9折 我被動我華新科打4折啊
那當然哀叫啊 我國劇打幾折 有沒有
各位你看一下國劇打幾折 1220到670
打對折啊
對不對 國劇幾乎打了對折 今天最低是608
不是打對折嗎
對不對 國具打對則 花心科打四則
這個才嚴重嘛 因為這種閃戶很多啊
閃戶多少
再給你看一下 看集保護術有看到嗎
對不對
以前都沒有國具 現在人手一張國具
本來21萬戶 現在48萬戶
莫名其妙一個多
兩個月多了27萬戶
欸這很多欸
這超多 這個國巨 這個人很多
那這些不穩定的賣啊 其實我覺得
華興哥占一個很重要的責任
那反正華興哥 處理掉啊
華興哥處理掉啊國巨也已經出現了 這個我們所講齁在所有下跌慣性裡面我們最希望出現一個東西叫做離開下軌的紅K
再講一次
下跌的股票呢 最希望出現的K棒是
離開下軌的紅K
那今天這跟紅K有點像
因為它也黏一點點
但是它已經很像了
代表說它的慣性改變
它的慣性改變取決怎麼樣
取決於我們處理掉華興客
我說華興客我會處理
為什麼會處理
因為只要他的量超過5000張
我就會處理他
我才處理
他處理起來你知道嗎
華興客處理起來
因為我要把他的賣壓給解決掉嘛
解決掉就是我去買而已啊
我不入地獄誰入地獄嘛
對不對
因為大家都套得很辛苦
套得很累
有的人要斷頭
小哥我要斷頭了怎麼辦
我說你不要反了
華新科只要超過5000張
我就立即打出力
我立即打
我
小孩子睡趕快去睡
好不好
待會有重播可以聽啦
待會有重播可以聽
不用害怕
趕快去睡
只是你不能抽獎而已
好啦 所以
這個這邊處理掉了
一切都沒什麼問題
所以我覺得明天過後開始
我個人覺得
我是沒去上理財達安秀啦
但是我個人覺得
我覺得華新科
被動元件整體是有機會指紋的
為什麼有機會指紋呢
ABF載板都可以漲停對不對
南電 南電新興
新興漲停 景碩漲停
他們還在天上呢
他們都在天上在背
對不對 為什麼我們華新科打四折
對不對 台勝科
台勝科還在天上
為什麼我們國際打要打五折
為什麼會
對不對我們被動是不會當年
我們被動是
看我們沒有對不對
被動的反攻號角我覺得應該在這裡
應該在這邊 你說什麼
應該在這裡 我覺得啦
個人覺得搞不好我錯
搞不好明天投信看我不會送
對不對 華信哥都在跌停
都在跌停我就沒辦法
我沒有辦法
你把華...
你把那個華興哥再砍鐵頂
我就認了啦
我認了好不好
我認了
換我賠
換我賠對啊所以呢跟各位講明天 請好好看別動言言 齁 好啦唉呦 才講到這裡 天啊
好 我們看第六個
這個
自從買了小哥處置神器
跟著小哥學操作處置策略
透過小哥的籌碼分析才發現
當主力籌碼後關鍵分析
從低檔大陸不舉轉到高檔婚禮好錢
骨骼面臨回檔壓力
張魯高都被處置忘了是從來曾經大好心
你看人家都知道
對不對 這學的都知道
對不對 達利991的都不知道
這個一定要再酸個兩句
991的都不知道
處置錢大量買
然後到牢
然後再被關
然後再處置停損
他才壞掉
你知道嗎
他才壞掉 頭殼壞掉
有沒有
他就是沒來上處置課嘛
是不是沒有來上儲置課
你有來上儲置課
你要買在這裡嗎
不會嘛 老師跟你講
他這邊一堆儲置你不能買
因為他隨時被關
他是連武被關喔
不是連三
他連三 第一款連三被關
連三被關欸
你懂嗎 連三被關
你去追
你追到連三 你打個問題
對不對 991A
各位 991A多少人
各位 99A多少人
這991的多少人 各位
991的多少人
33萬人
33萬人相信你
在6月18號的時候投進去20.68
現在投16.71
嘿
嘿大盤打9折你打8折
對不對 大盤打9折你就打8折了
對不對
你好意思 對不對
你給人家拿主動型錢
你不如去買0050
所以我們就說你買0050好不好
好不好
每次人家問我ETA我沒有買什麼
你買0050好不好
6月18號在這裡
6月18號107.3現在102.5
95折好不好
我看見有沒有
95折
0050是95折
再講一次
0050回檔95折
你00991要幾折
8折
所以你那要
要主動型的
有那厲害
我跟你講多頭很厲害
再跟各位講
其實主動型多頭很厲害
多頭大家當然厲害啊
你買我的基金 我有錢
我去買股票
我把股票買上去了 我還不厲害
對不對 我的衛食件都
都因為我自己把它買得很漂亮
就很厲害了
多頭大家都股神啊
再跟各位講 多頭大家都股神 對不對
問題是空頭啊
或是盤整啊
只要盤整空頭 你看怎麼
看怎麼辦
盤整一空頭
這以前我就跟學員講
我說主動型跟0050
長期而言
0050還是會獲勝
為什麼0050還是會獲勝
因為主動型EDF
他撐不了空頭那段期間
為什麼撐不了空頭那段期間
因為他得自己砍自己股票
他背後會有一個死亡的螺旋啊
你知道嗎 什麼叫死亡的螺旋
死亡的螺旋
喔 他有除息喔 好啦
抱歉 抱歉 他有除息
所以我們應該把除息給加回去 好不好
16.8再把除息加回去
0.7 加回去
是17.4
17.4 從這裡算出來喔 我們來看一下
20.68 17.4 哎呀
這個 17.4 除以 20.68
84 則
84 則也是
也是必讓95則差
也是比95則差
也是比95則差喔
啊
主動型的他在空頭的時候
再跟各位講
這個國外的數據都考證了
主動型在空頭的時期
那個修正的幅度
會比0050這種四支型的來的大
那最大的問題就是
他的成分股他得賣
為什麼得賣
因為這些人
有的人是六代同堂
你知道嗎 六代同堂
人家是花了房貸 融資 車貸
不信用途借貸 高利貸
什麼都來貸
然後去買你的主動型ETF
對不對
人家買花錢貸款
有利息要繳
然後你現在你的表現差
插到後面呢
有的人還做什麼事啊各位 最恐怖的 各位你看這東西我融資了融資這麼多
欸 融資
0050也出息
各位
好啦 所以你看這個算起來很差
那融資這麼多
這個股票只要回檔兩成
再跟各位講
你單純買00991A
繳你的戶頭只有991A
你買在高田 一回當兩成
你就得怎麼樣
你就得面臨追繳的問題
然後這些人面臨追繳的問題
要這樣抓
怎麼辦
這就是一個很大的問題
所以各位 你要開槓桿OK
請你多空都有
多空都有 要分散
什麼最分散 0050最分散
為什麼0050最分散
因為0050有一些很奇怪的股票
什麼中華電信 對不對
中華電信這不是夠分散嗎
這991月會買中華電信嗎
0050有摻一些很牛皮的股票在裡面
所以呢 它的股信就不會那麼
那麼活潑嘛
它不會一下子回來兩成
欸 這一個月還要兩成耶
你懂嗎
這一個月回來兩成 這很恐怖的耶
為什麼一個月回來這麼多
然後績效這麼爛 為什麼
啊就處置課沒來上嘛
對不對 簡單嘛 處置課不來上
對不對 老師有在教你沒在聽
別人的體驗課
這跟各位講 別人的體驗課 有學人跟我分享
老師別人體驗課
都在那邊說 老師有多厲害 就你的體驗課最有量
我說當然啦 我們是
我們平常 我們以前就是教育英才
我們這上課不太敢講太多廢話
怕學員那個喪失他的受教權嘛
所以你來上我的主事體驗課
我還是教你很多東西
啊這些教這麼多東西呢
你就不會怎麼樣
你不會在這裡買股票啊
懂不懂
你不會在這裡買股票啦
不會在這裡買
在這裡停損啦
你怎麼啊
這不會這樣子啦
經理人出
欸欸欸不要不要不要不要不要不要不要做處置ETF啦
好 各位那個留言區有報名連結那邊播開
喔 報一下報一下
很有用啦 你去聽聽啦你知道小哥處置課處置會不會很難做會不會不會欸 各位華新科我今天都大買給你看了
我今天買這幾檔哪一個不是處置
你告訴我
哪一支不是處置
我這幾支哪一支不是處置
全部處置
有沒有
全部處置啊
難道我上處置課我不講
我不玩處置嗎
我最討厭那種齁
說我吹個轉破
啊老師你會做公平沒有我定存
呵呵呵呵呵
啊老師為什麼你要定存
啊因為股票好恐怖我不敢做股票
欸不敢做股票
教我們做股票喔對阿
股票很恐怖你們做就好我定存就好
呵呵呵
我真的有遇過
有老師說他就定存了
哇塞你定存
啊你講得幾吹個轉破
果汁吧
跟各位講
華星哥一反彈了
因為他現在這邊都是沒有量的
所以他這邊事實上沒有什麼套勞賣牙
所以我期待他的反彈行情
我是期待啦
我不曉得會不會到啦
我不知道啦
我知道我就all in了
對不對 我知道
房貸車貸不信用途借貸我怎麼all in
有沒有 怎麼all in
我也不知道啊 我也怕怕啊 我也怕怕的啊
對啊 所以我只能買這些嘛
這是我的資金控款嘛
資金控款不要買太多嘛
不要買太多
那華新客這點跟日電貿這點
我是覺得很漂亮
所以我今天這兩個點我才買比較多
好好好 你趕快講講
太興奮了 講太多
來
看到哥友仇逼貓開始認識小哥
從到現在不夠短短10個月的時間
你賺我超過5年的薪水了 我才
很強欸
真的很強
覺得小哥最厲害的跟其他非議師投顧最大不同
就勇敢貼自己的
欸 我
我是事前貼喔
欸各位
我事前貼喔
我也沒有誘導你進來買喔
我只是短見搶反彈
你不要買喔 你不要買喔
我上去我會賣喔
上去我會賣欸
再講一次 上去我會賣喔
我沒有叫你買喔
我只是貼給你看我買的點而已
上去我會賣 再講一次 上去我會賣我不是那種一張不賣奇蹟自來欸 依永傑說一張不賣奇蹟自來然後底下有學員在那邊欸 那個感謝師傅 我已經把
我已經當衝了
你這當衝狗 你怎麼可以當衝我們的股票
一張股票 一張不賣奇蹟自來
後來人家發現 哇 這個師傅賣到剩一張
後來的檢調發現 這師傅都在出貨
叫人家一張不賣奇蹟自來
結果自己賣到剩一張
然後一直出貨
然後後來就被抓了
就被抓了
他現在落跑了
落跑了
我們沒有 我跟你講 我買的就是要賣
我買的不賣幹嘛
我買的就是要賣
再跟各位講 我買的就是要賣
好不好 你不要說 小哥你買的你出貨
我不出貨 我買幹嘛
我沒叫你買好不好
我沒叫你買 我只是告訴你
我買在這點位好不好
本來這個點位我覺得買的還不錯
但是我沒叫你買 好不好
早上去我要賣喔
再跟妳講早上去我要賣喔
好 而且我們是提早講
我也沒有說後面講
早上去就跟你講 我早就買了
不能這樣嘛 對不對
我要先貼給你看啊 對不對
明天漲不漲 跌不跌 我不知道啊
至少我們貼了嘛 對不對 我們至少貼了
至少貼了齁
好
這樣看起來
請問小哥最厲害的跟其他分析是投入最大不同
貼自己的反彈 有錯也認錯
拜託交給 賠錢給你看啊
沒差啦 賠錢給你看
同志願分享自己的方法
欸 有人問啊
被動搶反彈 當然是搶反彈啊
你期待他回升嗎
你期待華興科漲到645嗎
你期待嗎 我不敢期待
反彈而已啦 當然是搶反彈
欸到645 現在273到645要去多少欸
要去多少 你期待他回升嗎
回升就是說你要過645
反彈就是說可能不會過645
那反彈的最佳滿足點在哪邊
那反彈到月線我就很開心了
我超開心 好不好
反彈到月線或者鬆到那啥
鬆到歪語
嘿!
IHG 州寄飯店 我全
欸 我今天這樣子可以賺了
我今天在那邊做的這兩檔的未遲見損一帶四百萬
我大概還可以住個幾天啊
喔 400萬可以住幾天
400萬可以住個
200多天欸
欸 200多天欸
我一個月去住一次 我還可以住20年欸
今天買完一個月去住一次 我住20年欸
我可以住到2046年欸
對不對
所以我們都跟學人講 你好好學好不好
你口皮好啊 餓好嘛
你不要亂不亂
欸 站穩才能做多
站穩
站穩聽都歐語
對不對
站穩都不用玩啊
對不對 每次都要再確認
確認 確認也不用玩
確認你就不用玩了啦
確認
你
訊號傳遞得要折
訊號出來你就要做
不用等確認
好
各種工具說給學生聽幾乎不堂師
讓人信不口誤
從專業上 從心理上都願意相信小哥
都跟你先講在前面做給你看
你再不信或怎麼不在
所以
要來酸我的趕快酸一酸
酸一酸我們把它封鎖
封鎖色的
你不要來看我啊
你連這個你都不信
你的邏輯就死亡了
好
希望未來空頭行情小哥也能多分享
空頭很好做啦
跟各位講空頭很好做
很好做啦
當沖繩器
秋天的股票早出來
早出來
很多秋天的股票
後面都只是反彈而已
再跟各位講一次
秋天的股票呢
很多後面只是反彈
只反彈而已
他不大能這樣子
不大能 不大容易啦
你自己看金金
啊你要叫他彈到1、3以上
這困難重重啊
這叫秋天啊 這困難重重啊
星星你要彈過去
叫多少嗷嗷待哺
有啊 這頭戲也嗷嗷待哺
這閃路也嗷嗷待哺對不對
這不一隻閃路的星星都等著你來解救他結果一彈上去隔日蔥也要賣欸隔日蔥也要賣隔日蔥啊今天群英大安隔日蔥啦
應該是啦
隔日蔥吧 隔日蔥
隔日蔥也要賣
解套也要賣
喔來看主力
看主力有沒有賣喔
假如主力還要賣的GG啊
主力也要賣
有發現嗎
隔日蔥也要賣 解套也要賣
那哪有可憐
哪有可憐
一下子 一直往上走
很難啦
主力要賣 隔日蔥要賣 解套也要賣
所以現在 你看的很多鉤片
都是反彈而已
反彈 都有各式各樣的賣壓
再講一次喔
都有各式各樣的賣壓
各式各樣的賣壓
就這樣子喔
好
所以這個啊這個
喜歡主流跟兔好我送給你啦
好啦然後
這學人戰機喔
上次戰機有貼給各位看了
欸我看一下
這又是到舊的
上次有更新新的給各位看
各位有幸運可以去看啊
好 最後我們工商一下
唉唷 今天特別的
熱門講座客戶影音
系列組合均衣價
喔 這個不錯喔
組合均衣價6666
熱門講座客戶影音
系列組合均衣價 關鍵分點股票當中
唉唷 這麼便宜喔
我再加一加 組合均衣價
喔 很便宜喔
各位可以看一下
哇 這個
欸 有我的黑粉喔 我有時候覺得
欸 小哥以前有
小哥 我訂閱你PP
那我那個訂閱一年
以前有啦 現在沒有了
我訂閱一年都賠錢
你的PP沒有用
你訂閱一年都賠錢 你還可以訂閱一年
你早就可以退訂了
又沒有人阻止你退訂
退了你就直接退訂就好了
訂閱一年都賠錢你還一直聽一年你是愛上我還是怎樣一直愛上我愛你覺得沒有用 退訂退訂 趕快退 趕快退沒有用 趕快離開
趕快離開去找別人
去找別人 別人比較有用
好啦 這個喔
這個工商服務一下
來
這邊 四大課程組合
籌碼組合
喔 新手籌選
布林組合 初階加進階
唉呦
當通組合 初階加進階
古旗加放空
各位可以挑
還不錯喔
各位可以看一下喔
好啦 那這個全鎮進階班
這進階班喔
會講的比較細
歡迎各位來上
歡迎各位來上這個境界辦
好 那交易筆記板呢
這是九折優惠券 各位有需要的可以看
然後呢 這邊的這個序約率呢很高啊
各位有趣可以看
好 那這是我的書啦
那最後呢 欸 我已經10點半了
喜歡今天直播呢 歡迎按讚訂閱留言觀看心得
抽景品娃娃跟軟體
即便玩玩還是一樣我們也可以抽那個MIFIA
世界盃足球賽結束了
還是可以繼續抽MIFIA
現在QS天不要守在
來 我們來看一下問題
全正進階班的台中場只要上課
各位看一下
好,我們來抽一下喔
這邊的線上亂數產生器
來,然後這邊是1到30號
哇
這個還是日本房子的廣告抽啦18到27好18到27啊
好啦
那我們今天的直播呢就上到這邊啦
非常謝謝各位的觀看
今天很多人看
很多人看喔
麻煩幫我按個訂閱啦
訂閱
各位看一下現在多少人
9.73萬人
哇
再差
這個2700個人
我就可以破10萬了
耶
歡迎各位加一下
我們下次直播再跟各位講
好 那想知道
最後呢跟各位講
想知道為什麼我今天會在這裡買的齁
我今天直播會跟各位講清楚
今天在PVA會跟各位講
我為什麼會買這個點
事實上呢
看到一個很關鍵的東西
看那個很關鍵的東西
反正呢 我在直播跟各位講這個事情啦
我在PV跟各位講這個事情
因為這個
還是
給那個訂閱的福利嘛
為什麼要買在251
為什麼買在163
為什麼
所以要跟各位講一下
好啦
好
呃
長廣賠錢我也賠錢啊
長廣我也賠錢
呃
賠錢
還好啦 找機會報仇就好了 好不好
這個做股票不可能沒把頭賺啦
跟哥哥講 不可能沒把頭賺
賠錢就賠錢
我們是面對賠錢
華西哥我之前也賠錢啦
我不只華西哥賠錢 我富鼎也賠錢啦
我富鼎也賠錢 好不好
富鼎我也賠錢
我買完之後他也是往下跌 我也賠錢嘛
但是我昨天做一件事情
跟哥哥講 賠錢就賠錢 我不會跟你講說
我賺錢啊 沒有
我們做股票不可能把把賺的
我們一定會遇到賠錢的
再跟各位講喔
做股票一定會有賠錢的
那賠錢怎麼辦
賠錢怎麼辦
賠錢你就很簡單嘛
找個點買進
然後上面把它都出掉就好啦
對不對
你買227
你賣230很開心的嘛
對不對
你買227賣230是不是很開心
賣236很開心嘛
對不對
假設你買成本270
假設你負頂200期好了
然後227你也不敢動
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:30:00 起〕